now just as a matter of curiosity this
identity is actually really really
important it has it's so important even
has a name okay it's cold I mean yeah
it's cold
Pascal's identity that's cool who's he
he is well he was a French mathematician
Blaise Pascal and he's most famous well
at least I think I think for most people
who learn math he's most famous for his
triangle Pascal's triangle okay and how
do you build Pascal's triangle the way
it works is you you start with these
three numbers up the top there kind of
by definition but then to get each of
the subsequent numbers what you do is
you add up the two numbers above each
number so for existing APIs - you take
these two ones and you add them up okay
or to get this this for you take the 1
and the 3 or the 6 comes from the 3 and
3 right now one of the most important
things and the most important insights
in binomial theorem is realizing that
adding up numbers is not the only way to
build Pascal's triangle there's another
way to do it you can write it in all all
in terms of binomial coefficients okay
and you can go ahead and get your
calculator and verify these results and
that you know Fritz the to choose one is
to to choose naught is one three choose
naught 3 choose 1 3 choose 2 3 choose 3
and so on all of these numbers line up
exactly it's really interesting there's
a lot of theory behind this and it's a
very um it's a very mysterious kind of
thing well not that mysterious once you
dig into it but anyway why what does
this have to do with the identity we
just proved well we just proved that uh
n choose R plus 1 sorry yeah that's
right is equal to n minus 1 choose R
plus n minus 1 choose R plus 1 well
let's just take some values let's for
instance say or I don't know it let's
let n equal 4
okay let's R equal say - ok so if this
is 2 that's 2 plus 1 right so that's
that's really for choose 3 ok what do
you have on the rain
inside here you've got n which is 4
minus 1 choose 2 add 4 minus 1 choose 2
plus 1 so what you've got is 3 choose 2
plus 3 choose 3 now can you see what
this is doing right 4 choose 3 that's
that's over here and it's saying well
how do you get that what's that equal to
well it's equal to 3 choose 2 plus 3
choose 3 which is these guys okay and it
doesn't just work for you know N equals
4 and R equals 2 this this sort of means
look for that n throw you can see that
the top number in your NCI is which row
you're on the 0th row first row second
row third row fourth row you pick pick a
couple of terms R and R plus 1 what
they'll equal to is term R plus 1 on the
next line you can do it for any one
right so this is a really interesting
identity very very fundamental
I hope the proof makes sense to you and
good luck with your rest study of
binomial theorem